le 18 décembre, la Chambre des
représentants a respecté son
devoir constitutionnel et a voté des articles
de mise en accusation contre le président
des États-Unis
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
de quitter ses fonctions avant la fin de mon mandat
est odieux à tous
mes instincts.  corps mais en tant que président, je dois donner la
priorité aux intérêts de l'Amérique donc
je démissionnerai de la présidence à compter
de demain midi Je veux que vous m'écoutiez
Je vais le répéter Je n'ai pas eu de
relations sexuelles avec cette femme
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
le Sénat va convoquer un tribunal de
mise en accusation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
leurs actions dépravées aujourd'hui brazii Les
démocrates de la Chambre de Nancy Pelosi
se sont marqués d'un marché éternel
[Musique]
Je jure
chaque jour au procès du
impeachment de Donald John Trump, le
président des États-Unis,
maintenant Pandey, vous rendrez une
justice impersonnelle conformément à la Constitution
et aux lois, alors Dieu vous aide à le faire
[Musique]